this will be more Club so this will be a
more conceptual talk so to ask lots of
questions so this is based on a couple
of joint papers with various subsets of
Jacob sign heart Mikaela Meister and
Moses mostashari sir
Jacobs a PhD student was coming more
from a ML background but that was more
on the theory side maybe I mikhail as a
master's student who will be applying to
PhD programs next year he's nice so this
working is motivated by this question of
so to what extent can you develop
algorithms for maybe estimation learning
optimization that are robust to kind of
a very significant fraction of untrusted
data so the general setting that we will
think about in this talk so you have n
data points and some alpha fraction of
them are drawn from kind of say the
distribution or phenomena of interest so
you know maybe your goal is just to
estimate some property of this
distribution or maybe you actually maybe
the data points are kind of XY pairs and
you'd like to perform linear regression
over them or maybe there is a more
complicated object and you'd like to do
some convex optimization over them
whatever
so alpha any of them are drawn from the
account from a distribution or this
phenomena that you'd like to understand
and then we make no assumptions about
the remaining 1 minus alpha n of them ok
so the remaining ones could be could be
very biased it could be noisy they could
be arbitrary they could be you know
maliciously chosen and at least some of
our results will apply even if they're
maliciously chosen as a function of the
remaining as a function of the good data
point
and the goal is going to be like an gold
standard would be to answer whatever
you're trying to do whether it be
estimation or learning or optimization
as accurately as if you actually knew
what the subset of the good what the
subset of the data consisting of the
good points were and the goal is the
good the the that's the goal and this is
kind of the gold standard you know how
how closely can you approximate this
okay so I won't belabor the motivation I
just want you to mention a few things so
so maybe some people remember this there
is some 2014 there is a this tweet from
The Associated Press Twitter feed saying
breaking two explosions the White House
rock obama injured and then there was a
flash crash in the market and not quite
sure what there was time resolution is
here but most of this flash craft seem
to have been caused by these algorithms
that are these are online algorithms
that are monitoring Twitter feeds
newspaper articles and so on and are
trading very aggressively based on their
chemistry and semantic analysis of
avenues okay so these are come very
think that these are kind of machine
learning things that are trying to very
opportunistically jump on you know onion
okay so you know most normal people
would see this and kind of realize that
well there are a bunch of Twitter feeds
that had been hacked in the months
before this most people kind of realize
this is probably a hack Twitter feed but
of course you can't really expect or you
couldn't really expect machine learning
algorithms to to realize sort of things
they were the punchline of this is just
so lots of machine learning algorithms
that are extremely sensitive to
patrolling in some sense so you can't
actually make money on this but what
happens is you know at the end of the
day they review things and they roll
back all the trades that happen during
this window okay so this isn't actually
valuable get rich quick scheme
so as more and more machine learning
algorithms are kind of deployed and our
trained based on you know who knows what
data so it's sort of - well they're two
different settings where I think
theoretical contributions to kind of
developing robust machine learning might
be really useful so one of these
settings are cases where you really do
want provable guarantees and think of
this as kind of security from the point
of view of security right so so it's
nice to have I know we don't have cap
great crypto approvable guarantees but
it's nice to have some some kind of a
very robust foundations for things like
crypto and security okay so if you're
going to develop a self-driving car or
you know or or some Internet of Things
devices which are training their models
based on data that they're gathering now
for some of these settings you really
would like some algorithm that has some
provable robustness guarantees and says
look even if even if you know a bunch of
a bunch of people by Tesla's I would fit
their garage with with movie screens and
feed in a bunch of garbage data I don't
want the learn driving model to be kind
of corrupted by this okay so security
settings are one area where you know you
really might want things have provable
guarantees not just things that you know
seem to work on on some data set and
then there's another setting where where
I think Siri actually could could say a
bit and these are settings where we
actually do need better algorithms so
just a few examples so there's a lot of
a lot of the big machine learning data
sets are based on crowd-sourced labeling
so imagenet you have all these images
and then you farm out the labeling task
to mechanical turquoise and you pay them
for a you know for however many images
they label and most of these truckers
just want to make money subject to not
being I mean they just want to make
money and they want to do canvas as as
quick a job as possible subject to not
being marked as as incompetent okay and
you know the current ways people
aggregate these sort of somewhat
untrusted ratings is very heavy-handed
redundancy okay and and other mechanisms
that's are pretty easy to easy to
undermine so you know if you have better
algorithms for have being able to
aggregate untrusted data presumably you
can get more better labels for the same
prices there's also the kind of general
trade-off between the amount of data you
can collect for a given you know amount
of money and the quality of that data so
maybe you can get a very small but very
clean data set or very large but kind of
rather rather dirty data set that's
worth understanding kind of information
theoretic trade-off in what you can pull
out to these different data sets okay
and there are other there are other
settings where robustness even in this
have a very adversarial sense might be
useful so so this question of peer
grading and massive online courses so
this is you have some assignment you
want the people in the course to grade
each other's assignments and there have
been various anecdotes where you have 30
percent of the class that's all
colluding to inflate each other's grades
and this sort of thing so so there are
some practical applications of this and
then there's a kind of the big-name
applications like aggregating Yelp
reviews where some fraction of the Yelp
reviews are the restaurants across the
road that's giving you a restaurant a
bad review to boost to ascend right so
this is a very real problem and there
aren't great solution
so a bit of the context so um so those
long history of studying kind of robust
learning and robust statistics from the
statistics community I feel just
probably talked about some of this
yesterday sorry I can do that but so so
most of the historical work on robust
statistics can focus on a few rather
specific kind of metrics that determine
how how vulnerable your estimators are
to bad data so this notion of the
breakdown point there are other notions
of the influence curve and the
sensitivity function of estimators most
of these ye are focusing on very
specific of aspects of what happens
through specific estimators when you
start adding bad data and in
particularly they kind of maybe they
don't do a good job of understanding the
actions though the complete trade-off
between information theoretically and
computationally kind of how does the
error that you end up with vary as a
function of the amount of of bad sex
um so I also just wanted to make this
distinction so agnostic learning there's
also quite different from the setting
that we're talking about so an agnostic
learning you're kind of you're not
making really any assumptions on your on
your data and you're just saying well if
the data is very funny we're going to
lower the bar okay in that we're doing
we're going to say look you know just
try to do as well as you can given how
bad the data is so this Gnostic learning
is another Keva approach to dealing with
messy data but quite different from arts
from the setting we're thinking about
right so so in our setting yes you have
some garbage data but you're only
measuring yourself based having
comparison to the good fraction of the
data so you're not trying to kind of
that best you're just trying to throw
out the bad data you're not actually
trying to accommodate it and come as we
will see it sometimes it's this
distinction that agnostic learning
you're trying to can't do something with
all the data whereas in our setting
you're really only trying to do
something with the good data and this is
going to be one reason why in our
setting we can get pretty strong
positive results efficiently where as an
agnostic learning you know there are
lots of results many of which are due to
Vitaly so showing that it's agnostic
learning in many settings is np-hard
okay so there's there's been some very
recent progress from the you know theory
and the machine learning communities on
learning in this in this robust setting
so there is a series of papers from
Basia and collaborators that are
thinking about robust regression and the
case where you have a rather small
fraction of have arbitrary or malicious
points in our language this corresponds
to alpha being come very near one here's
our fraction of good points is very near
one
how could so I know the first paper I
think it was maybe at least 0.997
percent or maybe 9 97 percent of the
data needed to be good something like
that okay are you from so the yeah so
okay so I think I think the first paper
and second paper is a strengthening of
the first one basically um shows it in
some sense the the kind of naive
algorithm actually does pretty well so
what's the naive algorithm see we're
just fitting a linear regression so you
try to fit your linear regression as
best as you can and then you toss out
the points that seem for this away and
you repeat yeah yeah so there yeah it's
a nice result and this is sort of what
people I mean this is what you do in
practice like the old one it was also
worthless page right no so so that's um
yeah I mean certainly give arbitrarily
silly points then you know no one shot
kind of l1 or l2 penalty you can do it
can deal with this right you can imagine
doing like an L one thing and then
pruning the few points that are craziest
and then repeating and maybe they did l1
maybe they did L - but but but some some
iterated procedure like this where you
you can't fit the thing you look at what
the absurd stuff is you pull it out and
you repeat gets you some some constant
alpha that's that's pretty close to one
yeah sorry I uh good okay and then there
were the papers that were talked about
yesterday from some from Ilyas and
co-authors and ly Ralph and Paula who
were interested in this kind of
estimation question you know how do you
estimate say the mean and covariance of
some simple distributions things like
multivariate gaussians product
distributions and so on in this in this
regime where you know the fraction of
good stuff is at least a half at least
half of your data is good so so I'll do
this time quickly this is sort of the
intuition for why you should be
optimistic that that strong positive
results are possible and I think this is
the intuition behind that that works for
yesterday but feel free to correct me so
see we're in the setting where else is
2/3 so 2/3 of our data is good and say I
promise you that the good data is drawn
from some uniform distribution the
distribution over a sphere of radius 1
so in one dimension say this is your
good distribution what can the adversary
do well the adversary can add some point
sampled from a distribution like this
and then in some sense there are even
information theoretically we don't
really know where the mean of this
distribution is so you could be here it
could be here it could be here we don't
really know and the error that we could
the best error we could hope for would
be around 1/4 so in two dimensions this
is a good data this is the good spiracle
disk this is the bad stuff well this
isn't doing a very good job fooling us
right we can tell that there the bad
stuff is kind of over here and it's
sticking out too much and we can count
just chop it off so the become worse
thing that the adversary can do is
actually something like this to form
this town crescent shape and now we
don't really know where the truth is
inside this this region but you know the
air is now going to be going to be a bit
smaller because the adversary is sort of
more constrained to not sticking out too
much okay and in three dimensions you
know again there's kind of an analogue
here the intuition is definite if they
have adversarial malicious points are so
too weird they you know they they can't
stick out too much you can identify them
and remove them and this really
constrains the adversarial points to not
be too weird and this limits how much
they can come by if your your your view
of what's going on this okay
so this is why you should be sort of
optimistic that you know maybe
something's possible okay so so I wanted
to give a slightly more general setting
I'll give some motivation for it and the
more general setting ISM you know
suppose actually that maybe the amount
of good data is less than 1/2 so only a
third of your data points are good and
say it's still the goal is to learn this
mean of some spherical disk so in some
sense you have this obvious
impossibility right maybe there may be
our data looks like this this is
actually the good distribution this is
kind of the stuff that the malicious
this we have the malicious data and it's
impossible to know you know is this the
good one or just a good one is this a
good one doesn't there's no way of
knowing right there
if a third of the data is good maybe the
other 2/3 are drawn from two other you
know universes there's no way of telling
which is the right universe right but um
lets them you know let's still see what
we can do so there are two different
models that one can think about here
which are closely related so one is this
list covering learning model which was
have initially proposed by Vulcan Blum
and valhalla I think in in the chem
clustering setting and and here the goal
is you know yes you have n data points
alpha n of them are drawn from your
distribution of interest no assumptions
on the remaining one and now the goal is
to return something like a list of 1
over alpha of possible answers right so
in this case you know if our goal is to
return three possible answers with the
guarantee that at least one of them is
correct well you know one guess is here
one guess is here one guess is here at
least one of them will be correct right
so I guess a different way of viewing
this this question is asked you know in
the case where a majority of the data is
bad if it is the only thing that an
adversary can do to kind of make other
possible versions of the universe
what can the adversary actually destroy
the structure in the good stuff so if
the good distribution has some sort of
nice structure to what extent can
adversary hide that structure first just
mimicking it so in other places all
right so this is kind of the question
and that's a nice geometric question so
you have some nice structured thing to
what extent can the structure be
overwhelmed and destroyed by by some bad
data versus just being you know copied
in other places to some extent so that's
this question of can you output maybe a
list of 1 over alpha possible answers
and positive results for learning in
this model imply that you can learn in a
mixtures of these distributions and so
on so there's some extra reasons why you
might care about it all right so the the
other setting which is closely related
to this kind of list covering or list
list decodable learning setting is what
what we've been calling the semi
verified learning settings so again n
data points alpha n are drawn from
distribution to care about no
assumptions of the remaining ones and
now assume that you can get K and think
of KS may be a constant number I can't
verify data points which you know have
been drawn from the distribution that
you care about so again in this setting
you know all I need is one data point
drawn from the good thing it will be
drawn from here and we say oh this must
be the good thing
and here sort of the general question is
how can a very small amount of trusted
data let you extract the information
from a large become maybe very dirty and
untrusted data set this you have some
huge data set that's all mixed between
good data points bad data points so what
I think is not very small but trusted
data set let you pull out the
information from this cute constant oh
no no I'm thinking of it as say a
constant I think of it as maybe
something like one over alpha
or maybe maybe lastly I mean this
example you just need one day the point
in me it's a different way of thinking
about it is suppose you can suppose you
can learn in the list decodable setting
suppose you can output one over alpha
different hypotheses well now you know
maybe you could use your cage trusted
data points to pick which of these 1
over alpha things make sense and the
number of data points you should need
for this is now you know log 1 over
alpha all right so it's independent of
anything other than alpha even the
dimensionality of your space doesn't
really matter so ideally you want the K
points to be very diverse they want to
tend on the distribution but they also
should somehow cover the distribution
maybe I mean yes Oh will
yes I'm not yeah I'm not sure the extent
to which affair from the distribution
it's hard to force them to can be spread
but we'll see I mean for some you know
for what distribution is this gonna is
sort of our positive results going to be
possible well their distributions were
you know the tails aren't too skinny if
I have if my good distribution is kind
of something nice but with some weird
absurd tale it's going to be very hard
to figure out that this weird tail is
actually part of the good stuff versus
part of the bad stuff
so in some sense maybe the the results
we'll be able to get only really apply
in the case where it's with point
samples from the distribution are
actually had a spread out has a
distribution itself
so I wanted to give another view of it
semi verified learning setting so this
is part partially motivated by um by
talking with them some people in the in
the med school and this is so the
following this kind of a gross
caricature of some some problem that
they're thinking about so suppose you
have some enormous medical data set of
you know five hundred million medical
people's medical records and at some
point so you discover that oh you know
two percent of the population has some
some mutation and you want to understand
you know what can medical through
percussions or you know what are their
medical ramifications of having this
mutation so you have this big data set
of your millions of medical records but
of course most of these people you don't
know whether they have this mutation or
not however you can go and make a
special case study and take a hundred
people who you know do have this
mutation and you can you know sample
their blood do all this stuff and this
think of this K now as you know you have
a hundred people who have this mutation
this is your K verified data points from
the set of people with your mutation
alpha in this case is 0.02 two percent
of your big population have this
mutation and the question is you know to
what extent can you pull out the
information about the subset of the
general population who have this
mutation based on your constant size
cohort okay so
so I viewed it as the scam data database
prism so you have a big huge data set of
lots of mixed demographics you have some
tiny study group constant size case
study of you know some specific
demographic you care about the subset of
people with this mutation or the student
demographic and you're so asking to what
extent can you pull out some accurate
information about this cohort from your
large data set so this is another reason
why you might care about the setting
where we're alpha the count fraction of
good data is very very small because
maybe by definition you you're you care
about some small cohort
so don't worry about this will connect
this so so let me tell you a few results
okay so simply so think of it following
this will be a very very kind basic
estimation task so say you have M items
to evaluate think of them as papers okay
so you're you're the you're the PC chair
you have M papers to evaluate lots of
papers you have n reviewers and sub
reviewers and each of these sub
reviewers maybe will only evaluate some
constant number of items so maybe think
of rs.5 marine evaluates five papers
there are lots of reviewers there are
lots of there lots of papers I suppose
some alpha and fraction give you know
noisy but unbiased reviews if ever and
each reviewer submits a review say on
the scale of one to five for the paper
some alpha fashion gives noisy but
unbiased ratings okay unbiased with
respect to you if you're the PT chair
you know if you were to review them all
you would know how good they all are
okay we make no assumptions about
behavior of the remaining 1 minus alpha
reviewers okay and then in addition you
know you can personally review K papers
think of K again to some constant you
can review K papers and and the goal is
you know
well the question is kept how many
papers does every need to evaluate how
many papers do you need to evaluate in
order to get accurate evaluations for
say almost all some 1 minus epsilon
fraction of the items so you know you
have a thousand papers there may be a
couple thousand reviewers each of you
err review side papers at the end of the
day you personally will review ten
papers and then based on aggregating all
these reviews you want to get accurate
evaluations of all of the papers are you
assuming you have to say
here's all the other reviewers every
people no no no so this alpha faction
these are the people like you who really
know what's going yeah yes yeah so so
think of that yeah think of the Telfer
faction as being yeah
copies of your world view yes yes and
and you know these key things that
you're reviewing maybe you get the
ground truth maybe you just get noisy
estimates of it but again these are kind
of unbiased by definition maybe yeah
this I mean this is a strong assumption
that you get these independent and
unbiased readings from these people but
wait so um
okay so suppose R is one so this is each
sub previewer only reviews a single
paper so I claim that things are
impossible the only way to get at your
estimates of most of the papers quality
is basically to review everything
yourself
so each sub reviewer just uses a single
paper there's nothing you can do other
than doing everything yourself that's my
claim namely you get no information from
this large data set you know unless
alpha is very close to one did you guys
buy this
so if each person just reviews a single
paper the only information that contains
in this large data set of people's
reviews is just this distribution of
reviews for each paper there's no longer
any you know oh this person you've you
both this paper in this paper let's look
at these things together so all of the
summary statistics are just this set of
you know this distribution of reviews
for each paper and okay say say the
reviews are just binary so now the
system uses this number of people have
said yes number of people who said no
and there's you know there's nothing you
can do if the malicious fraction of
people decide to inflate some papers or
deflate others there's no way of seeing
any structure you just do this so if
half the reviewers are bad in other
words they can make every single paper
have exactly half of votes and half --lo
votes half no votes and there's nothing
you can do about this
so we're not a human there's a model for
example that you know in some contests
class that will get the white school to
a paper of sex race no no we just think
of this as becomes dad's checked items
these papers they have some underlying
score and the like-minded people they
are found good people are giving
unbiased sequence let's going to that
yeah okay so if you person just
evaluates one item then you need to do
everything yourself so coincidentally at
nips I think great they have this weird
sub reviewing policy where all the sub
reviewers you view exactly six papers
exactly in this Senate okay so um 302
two theorem so right so actually turns
out that everybody evaluates to two
items then suddenly we're in business
as long as the facts and the good people
is left so long as the fact of good
people is at least one quarter then it's
okay even for for the number of papers
you review yourself to be constant
independent of n independent of it so
let me parse the two theorems so the
first one says the number of papers each
sub review reviews is some polynomial of
one over alpha and one over epsilon so
how is a faction of good people epsilon
is the desired accuracy in our final
final output again this is independent
of n the number of items so if each
person views and constant number of
papers then at the end of the day you
the PC chair also can review a constant
number of papers and in additionally
this holds when the number of items is
on the same order as a number of
reviewers so yeah you know you might
need a constant factor
probably dependent yet the contracted
dependent on alpha and epsilon more
reviewers and papers but you know
constant factor each sub reviewers happy
reviewing constant number you're happy
reviewing constant number everything's
good the second theorem is trying to ask
what's the smallest fraction of good
reviewers that you can tolerate there's
only two percent of the people in your
population have this mutation can you
still do something work yeah what can
you do
so here it's okay at the number of items
each review or evaluates it's just
logarithmic and one over alpha okay so
you know if if each person evaluates
five items it's okay if the ration of
good things is something like one over
two to the five really small and at the
end of the day you still need to
evaluate just some constant number of
things dependent on the Alpha Epsilon
and the big caveat to this result is
that actually you will need lots and
lots of reviewers the total number of
viewers need to actually be something
like n to the R so here you have the
number of reviewers m on the same order
as the number of items here you actually
do need a lot more reviewers okay but
you can you can get this kind of
logarithmic dependency which might be
relevant and so these are kind of the
two main result your probably finish in
like three four minutes
so let me let me sketch the intuition
behind cab the first the first theorem
okay so suppose this is our this is our
matrix of ratings so say the maybe I
switched Annan M definitely matter so
say the columns are the papers the rows
are the reviewers and this is entry is
you know the the reviewer is rating for
paper J and you know so this is very
very sparse okay so each each row of
each reviewer just review two or three
papers each column each paper was only
reviewed by some constant number of
reviewers so if you look at the sub
matrix consisting of the good reviewers
this sub matrix will be extremely sparse
extremely noisy but it's basically a
sparse noisy version of a rank one
matrix okay so if you have a think of
like a stochastic block model right so
that's example of rank two matrix that's
extremely sparse extremely noisy but you
can it's basically a sparse noisy rank
two matrix and lo and behold even given
a constant number of non-zeros in each
row and column you can pull out the
block structure you can learn the rank
two matrix so even though this is barson
noisy if all you had was the good
reviewers it would be okay even in the
constant density regime very sparse
array noisy but basically rank one
matrix okay and then there's the
question of well to watch extent can the
bad rows the bad reviewers can pervert
this nice drink one noisy sparse but so
basically ring one structure and the
answer is we basically can't okay so if
you if you do things correctly you can
come limit the effects that I've add
rows can have on the structure of the
good stuff and pull out the below of the
good stuff again you can do this with
with a soak convex program so you're
basically saying
two exes our data and you're saying find
me a matrix why so fill in time you
dense matrix why that's as similar to X
as possible subject to some sort of
nuclear norm constraint and also subject
to each of the rows of Y not being too
powerful not pulling things too much so
intuitively I mean this sounds plausible
right we're going to do some kind of
nuclear in or minimization this is like
you might have l1 minimization the
matrix world and then we add some extra
constraints preventing an arrow from
pulling pulling things too much and what
can happen here well what can the bad
roads do they can create their own kind
of noisy sparring one subspaces that are
different from this one but if this is
an alpha fraction of the data they can
only create one over alpha of these
other rank one subspaces and now you the
the knowledgeable PC chair can review a
bunch of papers and figure out which of
these rank one subspaces is actually the
right one or if you want to output a
list
well you'll kind of get one over alpha
different possible answers with
different possible vectors of underlying
qualities of the papers and you can
output this
yeah
design by assigning which yeah that's a
good question right so okay so here
we're going to tell we're assuming that
we are assigning things to the to the
reviewers to be reviewed at random it's
okay all we need to do is assume that
the good people are reviewing things
that random the bad people can pick the
papers they want review one class
continues you know can you do better if
you say do things adaptively if you
assign the small batch of papers for
people to review and then think of it
and then assign another batch I'm not
quite sure the answer this question yeah
I'm not sure in some sense you do need I
mean if you think about the this is just
the adjacency matrix of a graph like
forget the ratings just stage on whether
or not you bring some you do need this
thing to expand and that does kind of
limit what you what you can do if it
doesn't expand then there's some sense
you're stuck well yeah
okay let me just end in two minutes with
so you can extend the same intuition to
much more general settings
so rather than Sam rather than thinking
of you know evaluating papers or
sampling data points imagine we're
sampling a bunch of convex functions our
four fraction of them are drawn from
some distribution over convex functions
we make no assumptions about the
remaining ones and our goal is to find
some argument W that minimizes say the
expected value of F of W in again the
semi verified or lifti code you know
bliss decodable sense so what does this
correspond to not even sure if I yeah so
you can mean the learning views these
FIS are kind of your loss functions so
say we're just trying to do estimate the
mean of something so each person say has
some X I I could interpret this X I Y or
X I as actually a function f of w where
F of W is W minus X I squared just have
some distribution I sample exodus from
it and interpret each X as a function
function of W where you know the
interpretation of X I is the function f
of w is w minus X I squared then what is
the argument of this minimum what W
minimizes the this average I mean yeah
okay so so you can phrase this problem
of estimating the mean in this view
where you know we are associating these
functions just the distance to the point
squared to each data point and similarly
you can represent linear regression and
other function other convex optimization
things in this view okay and you know
one can apply the same sort of idea in
this in this optimization setting and
one can get fairly strong results
provided at the distribution of f has
some nice properties and the nice
properties are basically that the
gradients of F are sort of consistent
and sort of concentrated so we have a
distribution over functions and they all
tell you to go in different directions
there's not much you can do if there's
some consistency then you can do this
kind of learning maybe I won't
superficially that looks pretty I looked
pretty similar to the to the other
setting let me just skip the very end
all right so this is this is my current
hope right so so in terms of the kind of
TCS view of learning so there are lots
of worst-case results and when the
results are positive it's great because
then you get very strong results when
but many many cases we get have negative
worst case results and in general these
are too pessimistic rate so if you say
things are impossible and some practical
person says yes but I did it what do you
do then so then there's also kind of a
lot of work on average case analysis are
making very strong distributional
assumption and in general you know this
this kind of set of assumptions often
leads to very strong results although
you know when these when these
assumptions aren't don't actually hold
then it's not it's not clear work where
you are right so most of these results
are quite brittle to the distributional
assumptions you make and this sort of
this kind of robust learning semi
verified list the covert list coverable
learning view of things I'm optimistic
that one can both get strong positive
results as well as can maybe getting
algorithm to actually perform well in
practice in part because the assumptions
you're making are rather weak right
you're making no assumptions on the good
chunk of your data you're making strong
assumptions on some of your data very
weak assumptions on everything else or
no assumptions on everything else and
you know maybe this is kind of a maybe
this is the right combination of worst
case and average case that can I can
lead to some good algorithms they lost
lots of open questions including this
question of you know say you do things
adaptively can you do better also a
[Applause]
default setting possesses mi-35 very
normal connection so by learning I don't
see any I don't see any more connections
to it although you know yeah I mean I
mean morally you can see